[Music]
okay john i want to go back to our first
segment we took a call from a lady who
uh mentioned a uh
an alphabet soup of maladies uh that she
it was a adhd ocd uh depression
everything else um
and then she was spending when she was
feeling blue yep to medicate
um
and i wanted to ask you about something
because we didn't have time in that
segment for me to interrupt uh and jump
in there but
doing financial coaching for 30 years i
have run into a ton
of i mean we've dealt with a lot of
addicts of course because 100 of addicts
if they don't deal with their addiction
become broke right it's a hundred
percent isn't it there's no you do not
make it out of addiction unless you're
broke or you stop the addiction one of
the two okay the second thing i run into
a ton is
legitimately diagnosed
bipolar yep where they're manic
depressive
and they haven't got their meds
straightened out if they're doing meds
and they haven't gotten good counseling
and coaching and so they've accepted
that this is who they are and it's this
dramatic swings
back and forth which affects every area
of their life but we see them as in
financial coaching we see the when they
go manic they spin like manic like a
maniac that's the word manic and so you
spend you spend like you're in congress
uh if you don't get this and uh but when
i've talked to them they are
too many times even here on the air
sometimes i would call i'm not a
therapist i'm not phd like you but i
just have learned enough about that
diagnosis and so forth because i've
dealt with so many of them that they uh
i think incorrectly
accept that this is the way it is and my
pushback is is that i've also met with
people that were bipolar who did the
work in therapy
and if they're going to do some pharma
if they're going to do some pharmacology
then they've done the work there to get
that balanced or it's not ruling their
life but they they've
made the uh the disorder
manageable towards healing
versus this is just the way it is and
we're always going to have money
problems because i got this so the way
i've framed it
and i i frame this with my students this
way with myself and i look in the mirror
with my friends and family
any of those diagnostics are a context
not an excuse
so they might
adhd they may paint a picture or where
you're going to lean in
that doesn't it's not a license to like
that's just how i spend then you need to
give away your debit card right so it
may it may impact the severity by which
you have
how far you have to go
to control your behavior
but it's not an excuse just to let
everything roll right so it it it it
provides a context but it's not an
excuse to to be out of control
and
it is
again i'm a lay person that's why i'm
throwing it out here because it's what
i've always believed
because i've seen the evidence on the
other side
it is not a
terminal diagnosis
meaning you don't have to die from it
this is curable
to the point that you you can get it to
manageable moving towards healing i'm
not saying they won't always deal with
it maybe at some level but you can
become functional you can yeah healing
is the language i use yeah yeah you
absolutely it's it's not a
um again we're speaking the bell curve
is broad on these things but
most people look at that diagnostic and
they say this is the a path open
this is the rest of my life that's right
it's an identity and it's not yeah
that's my problem it's a it's uh it's a
challenge we all have them some are
bigger some are smaller we've got them
i the other day i got i got a bunch of
genetic testing done from this doctor
north carolina's incredible
um i have something called the cookie
jar gene and it was like
462-911 and here's what he said i think
and you you and i may have talked about
this i think my wife's a serial killer
because she can open up a bag of cookies
and have one
and then just put it back
who does that i got a friend that says i
do a line a whole line of oreos yes
exactly yes
and here's what he told me he said at
the genetic level if there's an open bag
you can white knuckle your way through
it not he said your strategy for health
for the rest of your life
is stay away from open bags stay away
get them out of your house don't have
them there so
abstinence that's it don't buy them in
the first place your wife can have one
gummy worm like a somebody who
so you have a genetic sweet tooth
he just said this is good i really like
this he's great he's great but here's
the thing it's a context not excuse so
i can't have oreos in the house that's
just part of it right when i'm out of
town my white man they go crazy they go
to town because my kids don't have it
either but it's a context non-excuse
yeah you got bipolar you've got ocd
you've got adhd you've got seasons of
anxiety you've got seasons of depression
whatever the thing is it it's a reality
it is what it is it's a signal that
something else in your life's off and
the question is now what are you going
to go do about it are you going to go
get healing you're going to go see a
counselor you're going to see a doctor
what are the things you're going to go
do but it's not permission to sit you
know it's um i was dealing with a guy
one time in a session and he had a
serious anger
thing going on and um
again it's just showing up in the money
the only reason i'm dealing with it i'm
not qualified but i'm like dude
you like to stay pissed off all the time
like every time i'm with you you're
angry
and he goes
well that's just the way it is that's
the way i am i'm going well
just change yeah
bob newhart right stop it five dollars
right so it's like you know just stop he
goes what do you mean i guess he goes
well that's just the way my family is i
said your family is not responsible for
you being a butthole yeah you know
you're just being a butthole yeah and
you need to stop it yeah and he's like
dude
who are you i said you come in here no
what's going on this is affecting your
family pattern you cannot communicate
with your wife you can't get on the same
page with your money and you you get
angry and you go do stuff and and you
wear your anger like it's a badge of
freaking honor or something stop it the
great counselor terry reel says family
dysfunction rolls
down
family generations after generation
after generation like a forest fire
until one person stops and turns and
stares it down and says no more yeah and
that's it yep you learned that from your
parents and they learned it from their
parents well great and stop well and
families will name it i had a pastor
friend of mine he said it was out of
sight a phd in psychology as well and he
said uh that you'll name the besetting
sin
and then it becomes a badge of honor
like well we're just passionate people
no you also temperfest yeah exactly no
it's like we hold our liquor well you're
an alcoholic yeah congratulations man
we're all just kind of tolerant yeah
we're all we're just an anxious family
well stop
be about healing that yes break the
cycle change your family tree change it
and just like you can change your family
tree with debt and you can change your
family tree with wealth these are
behavioral changes this stuff overlaps
it all well how many people we we have
at the debt free stage that say
we just have to keep coming together
once a week and talk about our money
which meant we had to talk about our
priorities and our goals and our future
affected our marriage our marriage is
better yeah it's like ta-da you know
what i mean and how many of them go you
know i lost weight yeah that process not
because we were starving them but
because they said i got i learned this
thing called self
control
how many i can't tell you how many
marriage and family therapy friends i've
got that would love a tool
that a couple would commit to using for
a year or two years or for the rest of
their life it was just a reconnecting
tool it's like a magnet every week or
every budget a budget yeah yeah i've
actually known several that weren't
doing our stuff necessarily but marriage
therapists that they use they force the
couple to do a budget because it forces
them to talk and communicate on what's
important if you were sitting there you
just got back from thanksgiving and you
are st your teeth are still rattling
from whatever that experience was
you're a crazy family it can be
different yeah if you're exhausted and
you're by yourself it can be different
it it's your past is your past you got
to own it and then what comes next
someone turns
and breaks the chains like you said
you're quoting the author yeah terry
yeah yeah you turn and they face the
demon in the face and go that's it yep
this stops me i
this is the you and i did that i'm like
this is the last ramsay
it's going to be in debt and can can we
be honest about that for a second you've
got scars
you may die five years before you know
rachel and dan do right yeah you you
faced it and you got you faced the
forest fire you got burned you got scars
i was in a war they weren't in that's
right and somebody's got to say it stops
with me yeah this is it this is it the
last time you know what everyone
listening here
it can be any of you
any of you you can say i'm done that's
it i've had it that's it i've had it i'm
not living like this healing starts i'm
sick and tired of being sick and tired
and it not only stops with me it stops
with me and everybody after me that's
why i'm so pissed about this i'm done
with it what's up
this is how it works